would you buy a product from recycled
material that contains toxic chemicals
now you would
[Music]
these are hazardous chemicals worst of
the worst the first Pops 12 of them that
were banned under the Stockholm
convention but also nicknamed The Dirty
dust they don't decomposed and they
accumulate in the living organisms
sadly and that's the really sad reality
everywhere we can find them in the
environment we can find them sadly even
in the rain for example I personally got
tested and I have bisphen Lane uh in my
body which is not a pleasant feeling
these chemicals are harmful for all
living beings some of them can cause
cancer they have all sorts of harmful
properties toxic
for a production they have different
types of toxicity also in terms of
influence of the endocrine system
[Music]
they are not intentionally used in the
products anymore we knew in the past
that we were using harmful brominative
limitations in electronic products in
the very camera it's taking this video
but what we don't want to have is the
harmful chemicals from the electronics
that were used in the past ending up in
the new product
we were updating these rules to reflect
how the limits are getting stronger we
need to be even stricter on based on the
latest scientific evidence so I'm happy
that we include some of the latest types
of perforated forever chemicals that
were being bent this year under the
Stockholm convention but at the end of
the day really it's about making sure
that the worst of the worst chemicals
are not you know coming back in recycled
products